I'd be out you know in some some
whatever bar hanging out talking to a
girl and you know the girl will be like
what you know what you know be talking
for a while I'm like what sign are you
this is not 1970 by the way okay this is
like the in the I guess in the 90s a
Goldie oh you know what sign are you
gonna be like oh I'd be like Oh I'm
Sagittarius oh I knew it I knew you were
and then I say oh I'm actually not a
Sagittarius I was kidding they're like
oh what are you and I'd say um Capricorn
or is that a one yep I'd be like I'm
actually Capricorn oh I knew it and I
would do this to him four times
it'll be like this stuff is stupid what
you're talking about let's not play this
game you must be on the cusp on the cusp
of that's the thing
oh your your Moon is waning Sagittarius
you're in the you're the ambivert of
capital oh dude